Hey everyone, I'm Tessa,
and this is Episode 2 of IBM Cloud Now,
our bi-weekly web series
bringing you the latest and greatest announcements from IBM Cloud.
Today, we're covering what's new with IBM Edge Application Manager,
the latest Kube  version for IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service,
and how Travelping is using IBM Cloud
to innovate  driving with connected cars.
To start, we're excited to announce
that the IBM Edge Application Manager v4.0 is now available.
Edge Application Manager is a solution that is built on an open source platform
and runs on Red Hat OpenShift.
There are a whole bunch of new features and enhancements in the 4.0 release.
These are  our top 5:
First, this release supports the installation of the edge management hub
on Red Hat OpenShift Container Platform version 4.2
for the hub cluster.
This provides you with autonomous management features
that help you manage and deploy workloads  at massive scale.
Second, there is improved scalability for edge devices
- up to 10,000 edge devices per Edge Application Manager hub.
Third, this release provides a simplified developer experience
with OpenShift platform
and supports an edge-native programming model.
Fourth, you'll enjoy an enhanced user experience with edge UI.
And fifth, this release provides faster onboarding of edge devices
via bulk installation and  registration of the agent.
For a full rundown of
everything you'll get with the IBM Edge Application Manager 4.0 release,
hit the link in the description below.
Next up,
Kubernetes version 1.17.2 is now available in IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service.
This release includes a whopping 22 enhancements,
including the general availability of Cloud  Provider Labels
and a beta release for Volume Snapshot and CSI Migration.
IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service
now supports the latest 3 versions of Kubernetes:
1.15,  1.16, and 1.17.
There's a full rundown of all the new features and updates in the link below.
And finally, I wanted to quickly shine the spotlight on
a cool partnership that's going  on between
Travelping and IBM Cloud.
Connected cars with IoT devices are becoming more and more prevalent,
but these vehicles often experience latency issues
that can affect safety-related insights.
Travelping explored the problem and felt that it had to get the network
closer to the connected  devices.
With help from IBM Cloud,
the company used a self-developed Kubernetes cluster
to create a scalable, cloud-native packet gateway solution
that transmits the data to the vehicles.
The results?
Travelping and IBM Cloud's solution
reduces IoT latency by more than 95%
for real-time vehicle safety data insights,
saves resources by providing scalable services on commodity hardware,
and keeps data in the country by transporting the payloads to where the vehicles  are.
Very cool stuff,
and we've got a link below that gives you the whole story
behind this  innovative partnership.
Thanks for joining me for this episode of IBM Cloud Now.
If you want to learn more about the topics discussed today,
check out the links in the description,
and don't forget to subscribe to our channel
to stay up to date on what's going on in the cloud, now.